Good chance.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
This evening, I'd to share with you
a few thoughts
regarding a statement in the book of
Allah.
And this statement is not only a verse
from the Quran or a part of the Quran.
This verse represents one of the
fundamental elements that make up the
Muslims character and the believer's
character. Oftent times when we speak
about character, character, the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam had the best
character and indeed I was sent in order
to teach you the best of character and
all of these things that many of us have
heard. What usually comes to mind when
we think of character, a very
superficial definition of character and
that is, oh, he used to always smile. He
was super nice to everybody. Never
offended anyone. Everyone liked him
because he was so nice. This is not the
epitome
of character.
Character is more than that. This is
part of character.
Being gentle. Gentle and gentleness
is the essence
and it is the norm.
Harshness is the exception. It has its
place but it is the exception.
and so forth. But this is not the
epitome of character.
Character is much more broad than that.
When
was asked about the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's character, what did she
reply? I'm sure that 99% of us here have
all heard this before. She was asked
about the prophet's character and she
said, "Huh,
right. His character was the Quran."
Let's read the Quran. Let's look at it.
the Quran.
What are the characteristics that he had
that we find in the Quran?
Love for the sake of Allah,
anger for the sake of Allah,
a jealousy over the religion of Allah, a
standing for the truth even at the
detriment of of a person's own soul.
the way of the prophets, the of Allah,
the worship of Allah alone without any
partners, the rejection of fables and
fantasies and superstitions,
all of these things
from alhamdulillah
all the way to
this is all character.
that is for the believer. And so when
was asked what was his character,
she said his character was the Quran.
Meaning the best
example or the best one to exemplify the
characteristics of the Quran are found
in our prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam. There is a verse in the Quran
and its meaning is mentioned throughout
the Quran. This is elemental
in the Muslim and the believer's
character.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
this is the verse.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes the
people of knowledge.
Those who were given knowledge that made
them
appropriate witnesses
to testify to the greatest truth of all
of existence.
What is the greatest truth of all of
existence?
Huh? The greatest truth of all of
existence
is what?
The oneness of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. It is innate. It is inherent. He
does not need his creation to make him
one. He is one and unique and only
subhanahu wa ta'ala. That is the
greatest truth of all of existence.
And so Allah chose the angels
and the people of knowledge to testify
to that great truth. He says,
he says, subhanahu wa ta'ala, Allah has
testified himself
and his angels and the people of
knowledge who are upon justice and truth
that none is rightfully worshiped but
alone. law. There is no greater truth.
What makes these men and women
appropriate witnesses to this great
truth coupled with the witness of Allah
and the testimony of the angels.
One of their characteristics that Allah
described just a few verses before.
when they hear something from the Quran
or something from the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii wasallam that they do not
understand.
Their response is not to reject.
Their response is not to twist and turn.
Their response is
we believe in it. All of it is from
Allah. Listen to the words here. And why
is this a characteristic of the
believer? I am never, no matter how many
lifetimes I live, if I lived a thousand
times over, going to understand me
alone,
every aspect
of every verse in the Quran and every
single narration of the prophet
sallall.aii
No human being was able to do this but
[Arabic recitation]
as a said
that only a prophet is able to embody
the entirety of the sunnah.
There's going to be parts of the Quran
that I don't understand or don't know.
There's going to be aspects of the
Sunnah that I don't understand and I
don't know. There's going to be aspects
of the Quran and Sunnah that every one
of us is faced with that you will not
understand.
Either you will not understand
immediately
because you're not ready to understand
or because you don't have the tools to
understand yet or you're just not built
to understand it. This is the words of
Allah. The book of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala it is a miracle in itself that it
was made that the words of Allah were
made comprehensible to the human being.
This is a miracle in itself.
We are speaking about the one that has
no beginning.
Allah has no end.
Allah didn't come from anyone
and no one comes from him in the same
way. He was not begotten and he does not
beget. He is eternal. What does that
mean?
What does that mean? How can we
comprehend something that?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
exposed himself ever so slightly to the
mountain in front of MS and it turned to
dust
in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
MS said my lord let I would to see
you
and Allah said to him
he said you will not be able to see me
now.
However, look at that mountain, a
mountain.
Look at that mountain and if it remains
in its place and together, then you can
see me.
Allah says, "And when Allah exposed
himself to the mountain
in
the prophet sallall.aii
commented on this verse. He said
[Silence]
he said when Allah exposed himself to
the mountain, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam made this gesture with his hand
when he recited this verse. meaning ever
so briefly a fleeting exposure
and a mountain was rendered into dust.
This is a mountain.
This book, the Quran, comes from that
creator, subhanahu wa ta'ala. There will
be things in it that you and I don't
understand.
All of the Muslim scholars collectively
as a whole in every generation
understand all of the Quran, but no one
man understands it all.
And no one woman can. There's going to
be things that you hear in the Quran, in
the Sunnah, that you don't understand.
You might not be ready to understand.
What is your recourse?
What is your recourse when you're faced
with something you don't understand? Do
you argue?
Do you dismiss?
Do you twist the verse or the narration
to mean all kinds of outlandish things
to make it understandable or
comprehensible?
That's not the way of the people of
knowledge. The people of knowledge, the
first thing they understand, if they
don't understand anything, they
understand their own limitations.
and they've come to terms with the their
limitations and they know I can't
understand everything always
and so I'll be faced with things that I
don't understand and when I am faced
with one of these issues that I do not
understand.
I don't ask questions that I shouldn't
ask. I don't twist the text to fit my
narrative.
I don't interpret it in the way
that I feel and I think because now
we're in the era of I think right
everyone when they I think well you know
I feel right you get a 20-year-old
18year-old on a podcast they're going to
tell us now how the world works right
there they still haven't even graduated
high they're going to tell us how the
world work they have a million followers
they must know what they're talking
about right and then you Listen, I you
know what I think? I think that a
marriage in order for it to be a good
marriage, never been married, they have
no idea what they're talking about. No
guidance from Allah and no experience
from the world. What are they offering
us? They're speaking purely because they
have a mouth. That's the only reason,
right? This is the era that we're in.
The Muslim has the character to say
that's how it is. That's our religion.
I don't understand it specifically, but
it's from Allah, and that's what we
stand for. You're not going to
understand every single thing. And now
we feel we have to apologize for
our religion. Oh, what about this
narration? No, no, no. You know,
narrations, they're not really, they're
not the Quran. We only take the
Quran. Narrations, you know, they're
they're iffy. We don't know where they
really came from. You know what it's
like. And then you ask someone, why are
you speaking if you have no knowledge?
Why?
What are your qualifications to say
these things? You're saying things that
1,500 years worth of scholarship never
said before you. Are you the new
discoverer of Islam? Have you discovered
something about the Quran and Sunnah
that our prophet was unaware of and all
of the scholars of Islam were unaware
of? tell us. And so the issue is is that
you ask why are you speaking without
knowledge? Why? If you don't know, just
say I don't know. There's nothing wrong
with that. That's how the people of
knowledge speak. They say I don't know.
When they don't. As a matter of fact,
one of the companions said, "I don't
know is half of all knowledge.
Allah knows best is half of knowledge.
They say, "Well, you know, we have to
defend Islam." You don't defend Islam by
destroying Islam. That's not how it
works. Imagine with me the parable.
There's an Arabic parable of a man who
had a friend as a bear.
There was a man and a bear. They were
good friends. And when this man would
sleep, this bear loved this man so much.
He's a bear. He's a He's a He's a beast.
He has a beastial intelligence, right?
And so he would watch over this man as
he slept. He loves this man. He guards
him. And so once a fly landed on the
sleeping man's nose. And so the bear
took a boulder to smash the fly. and
smash the fly and his friend's head with
it. Right? This is what you're doing
when you're defending Islam without
knowledge.
Right? And so
this character that we need to instill
not only in our children but in
ourselves. Oftent times we speak we need
to save the children as if we we're
already safe and and they need saving.
Our children are are an extension of
ourselves. They are what we have made
them to be currently. And so when we
speak about this character of I don't
know,
you don't have to explain every single
aspect of everything that Allah and his
messenger said. You don't have to have
an answer for everything. You need to
know what's expected of you and you need
to have the character and fortitude and
courage to say that's our religion.
Why is it that way? It has a reason.
Allah is the most wise. I don't know
what it is, but if Allah said it, I
believe it. That's it. But how could you
believe something you don't know? I do.
I believe it. You don't have to. I do. I
believe in Allah and his messenger.
I don't need that belief to be
predicated and based on understanding
every single thing that he tells me. If
you imagine that you you give your child
commands, right? You tell your child do
this, don't do this, and your child is
not old enough to understand why. Do you
explain every single thing to your
children? Every time you say do this or
don't do it, you explain yourself to
them. What if your child said no? Why?
Why do you want me to do that? Because I
said so. I'm your parent and you're my
child. Obviously, my commands to my
children are based on my love and
protection of them. But to question a
parent at every turn, the child's mind
is not ready to understand these things.
And it may not be ready until 30 years
into the future. That is the difference
between knowledge and ignorance. You
cannot explain the difference. And so
the point here that we're making is that
whenever you hear a command of Allah, a
command of the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam do not demand an
explanation that fits your narrative and
world view at every turn
and unfortunately
in our time because of our environment
it's statistics are the ultimate
evidence right statistics show well if I
say how can you argue with science you
can't argue with science Allah said yeah
but the scholars differ on what that
means
Allah said that true but it has
different meanings and you have to be a
scholar to understand it. But statistics
show experts tell us oh experts tell us
I you know
all of these statistics and experts are
purchased and are in pockets. That's how
it runs. It's a money machine. This this
is not this is not a place built on
morals. It's a business.
these things when you look
a a a glass of wine a day is good for
your heart health in the little corner
and asterisk
funded research funded by the
National Wine Association. Great, right?
Drink more milk. It gives you strong
bones.
Funded research funded by the by the
farmers of dairy farmers of America.
Fantastic,
right? And you know what?
Just 80, 90 years ago, there were
commercials and billboards of doctors
smoking cigarettes saying this is a it's
actually proven that a pack of smokes a
day opens up your lungs, make you
breathe good. Who are those doctors
funded by their research? By the tobacco
industry. It was a huge scandal in
America. It killed half of the known
humanity of the time.
This it didn't stop. They didn't repent
from that. They just got sued until they
stopped. We moved on to other things
now, other fads. Why is it we do this
with our religion?
This is Allah and his messenger. If
Allah and his messenger say something
and my eyes tell me something else, my
eyes are lying to me.
And if Allah and his messenger tell me
something and my ears are telling me
something else, my ears are lying to me.
That is the that is the empire of faith
that Muhammad and his companions built
sallall.aii wasallam and they were proud
of that. This is our way of life. This
is how we are. Why is it that with women
you do this and with that's how it is?
Allah said
And this doesn't mean that we have no
questioning. We don't understand
anything of our religion and we blindly
follow. That's not what's meant. What's
meant is that we do not question Allah
and his messenger and twist these words
to fit what we think we know. In order
to learn, you have to be humble and you
have to open your heart.
And there is no other way to learn
except through humility and patience. We
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala teach us
that which we are ignorant of to teach
us that which will be of benefit and
consequence to us and to make
consequential for us what he teaches us.
Alhamdulillah.